the goat like
got that that golden leg
i got all the faith in him you know i'm
on the sideline praying but at the same
time
i'm like man i know tuck and do it he do
it all day in practice he just walking
around playing kicking field goals six
to five yards so i got all the faith in
them
that's lamar jackson talking about his
kicker justin tucker who made the
49-yarder to win the game delivered the
10th victory of the season for the
ravens sunday statement draft time chris
sims has the trivia question that
determines the first pick come on give
me your best or your worst oh well
you're screwed there's no way you're
getting this right jared allen no yeah
you're wrong dolphins kicker jason
sanders caught a one-yard touchdown pass
from punter matt hack in the dolphins
37-31 win over the eagles yesterday
who was the last kicker to catch a td
pass
yeah stats gave you the olds can i give
the finger to the control room without
actually yeah let's just give you the
stats okay let's just do this let's do
this
by decade let's go right right decade
the 80s okay
i was trying to be nice there i don't
know what to i don't know where to go
with that what was it pete stoyan turner
in 1977.
stash doesn't like that but i got it
listen okay i don't know we got to work
on this yeah we got to work on this this
is a problem
this is this is like a needle in the
haystack when we don't even know where
the haystack is i mean at least use
questions we have a reasonable chance of
getting so we can look like we know what
we're talking about but then again
anybody who's watching the show or
listening to it right that would hear
those questions they have to be thinking
what's wrong with the people who are
coming up with these questions right
what's wrong with it right well yeah
right i mean i mean you didn't know who
jim turner was i know who jim turner is
i had no idea caught a touchdown yeah i
mean how dare you you host a football
show and you didn't know that you get
what the video you are i'd rather have
the rig coin toss at least i had a
chance you'd outsmart yourself
right uh but that's doubtful i can't
outsmart myself i'm too dumb for that
all right desean watson will be my
sunday statement i mean how can i not
talk about it uh he just was so
impressive in the game last night
against a defense we're watching do
uh do historical things as far as past
defenses considered points allowed all
of those things that's secondary so
special desean watson basically said yes
new england you're special but so am i
and i am going to be a player in this
afc when it's all said and done and it's
his abilities that neutralize great
defenses like the new england patriots
the new england patriots don't have a
great pass rusher so they have to do it
with blitz and scheme and stunts
therefore at times they leave guys
man-to-man open downfield desean watson
i would argue is the best defense deep
ball thrower in football he's certainly
in that conversation and then when he
has deandre hopkins fuller and kenny
stills at his disposal it is dangerous
and it's tough to stop him because of
his ability to extend plays and his
accuracy down the field so watson i
think makes a big statement just in
going yeah i'm the man but also hey
don't forget about us houston texans and
i'm amazed what the texan been able to
accomplish two weeks after getting blown
off the field by the ravens 41-7 yeah
the idea that they have beaten the cults
on a short week and now handled the
patriots and they are right in the thick
of things and they have an outside shot
at a bye if the patriots continue to
stumble and all they have to do is tie
them but they hold the tiebreaker over
the chiefs they have the tiebreaker over
the patriots something for the texans to
build on and be proud of right i gotta
go lamar jackson look the passing
numbers weren't spectacular 105 yards
but to have his fifth career double
triple a stat that was identified and
invented by michael david smith an
important stat a rare stat it doesn't
happen as often as you think it would
where a player has a hundred or more
yards in any two statistical categories
lamar jackson is now second all-time
with five and it's only his second
season mike vick has eight for his
career there are four others who are
tied with four in their career lamar
jackson has four this year alone he is a
true dual threat 101 rushing 105 passing
and it keeps defenses on their heels it
makes it easier for him to pass because
they're worried about him running makes
it easy for him to run because they're
worried about him passing he's just an
incredible talent and like you got kyle
shanahan said last week when he runs the
football he becomes a running back he's
not a running quarterback he is a
running back he's not looking to get out
of bounds he's not looking to slide he's
not looking to throw out of the pocket
once he decides to go he's gone and that
decisiveness coupled with the agility
the speed the moves that move where he
put the guy on his butt that was
incredible
just on your i'm in the juke
and just down you go
it's it's incredible to watch and he
continues to be the favorite for the mvp
award yeah uh he is special he's a game
changer i mean we're seeing an offense
of vented around a guy that we've never
seen the skills of a quarterback like
this before be on full display
especially because of what they built
around him what are they going to do
next year if greg roman is the head
coach somewhere else
that's i you know hopefully they have
somebody in the wings that's learning
this system and how to you know install
and and come up with creative ways to
run the ball on a weekly basis yeah
that's the tough thing about it now you
know greg roman he's also there's not a
lot of lamar jackson's out there either
so hopefully he's not too jumpy to go
get a head coaching job but uh there
certainly will be a dialogue there
because i'm looking at their assistant
coaches i mean i'm telling you right now
you're right you if you're john harbaugh
yeah you're telling somebody pay
attention to what is happening yes uh
because you may be running this thing
next year yeah no doubt about that um
all right gosh there's a lot of places i
want to go here i think though i think
really i'm going to go to the steelers
front the steelers defense is another
sunday statement just because um
you know the way that game started and
the cleveland browns going down the
field the first two drives of the game
and you go oh gosh this doesn't look
good for the pittsburgh steelers you
know they settled in and basically shut
the cleveland browns offense down after
getting in the hole ten nothing uh the
the game was never the same really at
the after that point yeah the offense
found its way duck hodges made a few
throws but the defense just constantly
around baker mayfield
around the ball as far as throws he was
trying to make downfield they're very
creative in what they do in the back end
it's not always sound uh but with that
front four the way they can get after
the passer they have a few creative
blitzes to go along with it and then
they move a lot of people all over the
place disguises and uh
all types of tricks in the secondary to
me this the steelers defense has shown
improving that they're a super bowl
defense they really are and this
offensive they can just be somewhat
adequate uh the steelers are gonna be a
real pain in the butt in the afc yeah it
was more than adequate yesterday and i
had james washington on my list because
he had those four catches for 111 yards
27.8 yards yeah per catch which is just
incredible i'm gonna stick with the
receiver i'm surprised you haven't taken
aaron rodgers yet should i take aaron
rodgers just to keep you from taking him
in rounds you can you can see your day i
was trying to go around you know i got
to give devonta parker
i mean
this guy has been a disappointing first
round pick he's been injured a lot he's
been ineffective it seems like every
year they're expecting and waiting for
him to break out and this year he's
having the best season of his career 110
yards beyond his prior high with still
four games to go he had the the the
great performance yesterday um and and
helped fuel a dolphins team that really
isn't playing for anything and and to
see these teams that are done that are
cooked to have those those great
performances just like the love of the
sport and the tanking talk is over seven
catches for 159 yards two touchdowns for
davonte parker and ryan fitzpatrick told
me look once he caught the first one i
knew it was going to be his day and i
kept going to him and it was smart for
him to keep doing that play the hot hand
the guy's talented health has been the
biggest issue and yeah he clearly was
too much for these eagles corners to
handle yesterday who yeah are smaller
type corners there it's not a great
matchup for them to go against this guy
who's 6'3 and they're 5 11 and 6 foot uh
but they continued to feed devonte
parker and then even through a touchdown
pass to gesicki later in the game where
it was the same type of thing he was
just too big for jalen uh jalen mills on
the right side but
good for parker and you said it during
the show they got him signed up for at
least another year so they got something
to build on there whatever they do at
quarterback they'll have a marquee
number one wide receiver all right
i mean i could go with nick foles i have
thought about that but he you know he
made a crappy statement but it was a
statement nonetheless for the goat draft
i'm saving it but there's just i'm
giving you know derek henry's crossed my
mind jared goff we are you know i still
have a pick i know i don't care it
doesn't matter this one there's too many
picks to go around i'm going with darius
geist though we're making his sunday
statement we haven't talked about that
game a whole lot but the washington
redskins i think we saw a little bit in
the glimpse of their future uh as far as
yesterday played out hey dwayne haskins
the quarterback darius geiss the guy
that's going to be the bell cow between
the tackles he's had a tough go at it in
the nfl torres acl his rookie preseason
you know this past year was dealing with
injuries again early in the year
throughout training camp all of that
this was really his breakout game he's
had a few breakout moments and plays
over the last few weeks but this was a
complete game to have what was it 10
rushes for 129 yards i'm calling that
off the top of my head i know i'm
ballpark right somewhere there yeah 10
for 129 and really the two biggest runs
of the day that set up scores for the
washington redskins were the difference
in the game but good for him overall
good for bill callahan he's a o-line
coach he's designed a lot of good things
and uh darius geiss was was awesome
yesterday all right i give criticism
where it's due and i give credit where
it's due i had jared goff on our
pressure draft on friday when big cat
was working and you weren't and jared
goff responded to the pressure 424
passing yards two touchdowns 120.7
passer rating the most passing yards of
the week the only guy with 400 plus
yards and uh i you know look the rams
got embarrassed on monday night for them
to pull it together the way they did and
to win that game and i know it's just
the cardinals but the cardinals are
still not a bad team and uh good that
was dominating good for the rams and
look i still think their schedule down
the stretch is such that it's going to
be very difficult for them to get to the
playoffs and you know they're they're
going to be
a game behind the vikings tonight even
if the vikings lose but they're they're
they're there yeah
no it's all they can ask for is a chance
to be there down the stretch and they're
there we didn't think they'd be there
and they are yep and they got the
seahawks next week so they got to play
kyla murray yesterday now they get to
play a similar quarterback uh next week
and of course we know that they went
toe-to-toe with the seahawks earlier
this year and the seahawks with the
debbie on county problem that's
concerning to me so i mean the rams uh i
still uh this is not the last we've
heard of them yeah you know last week
was a butt whooping and they've never
been whooped like that as far as the
ravens game but yesterday was the the
proper way to bounce back all right to
go jared goff sims picks deshawn watson
the steelers defense darius guys i've
got lamar jackson devonte parker and
jared goff
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports